O HERE IN THE
"BLEACHER REPORT" APP EVERY
THURSDAY AT 1:00 P.M. EASTERN
TIME, IT'S "DRAFT CRASH COURSE."
I'M THE LEAD DRAFT ANALYST AT
"BLEACHER REPORT" CONNER ROGERS
JOINED ALWAYS BY MICHAEL FELDER.
WE HAVE QUARTERBACKS TODAY, WE
HAVE PROP BETS.
WE HAVE THE AFC SOUTH.
WE HAVE A LOT GOING ON.
FINALLY WE CAN CATCH OUR BREATH
BECAUSE THE NFL HAS BEEN A
LITTLE LESS CRAZY THESE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
HOW ARE WE FEELING RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M FEELING GOOD.
YOU KNOW, WE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
A SLOWDOWN.
WE DIDN'T HAVE NO REAL
BLOCKBUSTER TRADES.
NO, LIKE, MASSIVE EARTH-MOVING
MOMENTS.
I FEEL GOOD.
I FEEL COMFORTABLE.
LET'S GO AHEAD.
WE KNOW WHAT WE HAVE IN THE
SHOW.
WE HAVE SPECIFIC THINGS TO TALK
ABOUT.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
BLOCKBUSTER TRADES, I KNOW YOU
WENT INTO THE LAB AND CAME UP
WITH SOME TRADES.
I LOVE THIS PART OF IT.
AT LEAST WE CAN CONTROL THOSE
TRADES.
LET'S KICK IT OFF.
THIS IS KIND OF LIKE IF YOU WERE
THE GM, WHAT TRADES ARE YOU
GOING TO MAKE?
LET'S KICK IT OFF WITH KANSAS
CITY.
>> RIGHT.
EVEN AFTER ALL THE FREE AGENCY
MOVES, ALL THE BIG BLOCKBUSTERS,
THERE ARE STILL DEFINED NEEDS,
ESPECIALLY FOR A COUPLE
CONTENDERS.
I LOOK AT THE CHIEFS AS ONE OF
THOSE TEAMS.
THEY'LL TAKE PICK 29.
THEY PICK BACK-TO-BACK IN THE
FIRST ROUND, 29 AND 30.
THEY'LL TAKE 29 AND PACKAGE IT
WITH THE NEWLY ACQUIRED 50th
PICK AND CALL THE TEXANS AND SAY
WE KNOW YOU NEED MORE CAPITAL,
WE WANT TO COME UP TO 13 BECAUSE
THEY WANT A WIDE RECEIVER.
I KNOW THEY SIGNED MBS AND GOT
JUJU, BUT THEY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE NEXT FIVE TO SEVEN
YEARS WITH PATRICK MAHOMES.
THIS OFFENSE IS PREDICATED OFF
OF SPEED AND NOBODY HAS SPEED IN
THIS DRAFT LIKE JAMESON
WILLIAMS.
THE CHIEFS, THEY STILL PICK
TWICE IN THE FIRST ROUND BUT YOU
COME UP AND GET A PREMIUM
VERTICAL THREAT IN JAMESON
WILLIAMS.
HOW DO YOU LIKE HIM NOT ONLY AS
A PLAYER BUT IN THIS OFFENSE
WITH PAT MAHOMES?
>> I THINK HE'S A GREAT FIT.
HE CAN DO A BIT OF EVERYTHING.
THAT'S THE COOL THING.
HE'S GOOD AT ALL OF THE STUFF HE
DOES.
HE'S A NUANCED ROUTE RUNNER.
YOU SEE THE SPEED THERE.
TEMPO, TEMPO, TEMPO.
NOW I'M THE FASTEST GUY.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF FOLKS
THINK ABOUT THIS, YOU DON'T RUN
EVERY ROUTE AT FULL SPEED.
YOU SET UP THINGS SO YOU CAN
DRAW PEOPLE IN THROUGH STEMMING,
THROUGH LEANING, AND WILLIAMS
DOES IT REALLY WELL.
I UNDERSTAND HE WENT TO OHIO
STATE FIRST.
BUCKEYE FANS, DON'T BLAME ME FOR
IT, I GAVE YOU THE PROPS YOU
NEED, HE UNDERSTANDS THAT TEMPO
COMING OUT OF ALABAMA AND THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO USE YOUR SPEED TO
CREATE A PROBLEM WHERE A SAFETY
IS LIKE, OH, HE'S RUNNING A
DUMMY ROUTE.
HE WILL BE COMING BACK ACROSS.
WHEN HE STICKS HIS FOOT IN THE
GROUND AT THE TOP OF A BREAK OR
WHEN HE STEMS YOU INSIDE ON A
THREE QUARTER TEMPO TO GET WIDE
ON A FULL TEMPO, GUESS WHAT?
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO CATCH UP
TO HIM.
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF HIS GAME.
LOVE THIS TRADE FOR THEM.
AS YOU D WMENTIONED, WITH HOUST
THEY NEED TO GET A LOT OF
PLAYERS.
>> I LOVE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
THE CHANGING OF GEARS WITH
JAMESON WILLIAMS.
IT'S LIKE A PITCHER IN BASEBALL
THAT'S AN ACE, THAT CAN HIT 99
ON THE GUN, BUT DO YOU HAVE THE
CHANGEUP AND BREAKING BALL?
JAMESON IS SO POLISHED IN THAT
AREA.
FOR HOUSTON, THIS IS ANOTHER WAY
TO GET A PREMIUM PLAYER AT
THREE, YOU'RE STAYING IN THE
FIRST ROUND AT 29.
BUT THAT 50th OVERALL PICK, AS
WE DO THIS SHOW EVERY WEEK, WE
KNOW HOW VALUABLE THAT PICK CAN
BE AS AN EXTRA ASSET.
THE CHIEFS ARE IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY CAN SURRENDER THAT.
LET'S LOOK MORE IN THE
REBUILDING TEAMS CATEGORY.
A LITTLE COMMENT ON THE BOTTOM.
GOING TO NEED MORE THAN THAT TO
TRADE BACK AT 29.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE TRADE VALUE
CHART, IT MATCHES UP CLOSE.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER IN THIS
DRAFT, IF YOU'RE NOT COMING UP
FOR FRANCHISE QUARTERBACKS, AND
WE'LL GET TO THOSE LATER IF
THERE ARE ANY, THE COST IS NOT
AS SIGNIFICANT.
DEFINITELY A FASCINATING POINT
THERE.
LOOKING AT THE REBUILDING TEAMS
THAT MIGHT MAKE A MOVE THIS IS
ONE MORE THAT I THINK I CAN SEE
HAPPENING.
I DON'T KNOW IF I NECESSARILY AM
ALL ABOARD MOVING UP FOR A
QUARTERBACK IN THIS CLASS,
ATLANTA DON'T HAVE MATT RYAN
ANYMORE.
THE GIANTS ARE LOOKING TO BUILD
OUT A ROSTER.
ATLANTA TRYING TO SWAP EIGHT
WITH FIVE.
GET UP TO FIVE AND SURRENDER
PICK 58.
YES, THAT'S A HEFTY PRICE, BUT
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THEY ARE
SNIPING A DIVISION RIVAL IN
CAROLINA FOR A QUARTERBACK HERE.
I THINK CAROLINA IS CHOOSING
BETWEEN KENNY PICKETT AND MALIK
WI
WILLIS.
ARE YOU GOING TO GO WITH MARCUS
MARIOTA?
MAYBE, BUT THEN YOU ARE IN A
REBUILDING SEASON, OR YOU CAN
GET THIS STARTED NOW WHILE ALSO
HERDING A DIVISION OPPONENT, AND
YOU ARE STILL PICKING AT SEVEN.
THEN YOU PICK BACK-TO-BACK AT
SEVEN AND EIGHT.
I'M FASCINATED IF ATLANTA OR A
TEAM LIKE ATLANTA WHO NEEDS A
QUARTERBACK JUMPS UP TO BEAT THE
PANTHERS TO THE PUNCH, WILL IT
BE MALIK WILLIS, KENNY PICKETT?
SHOULD IT BE MALIK WILLIS OR
KENNY PICKETT?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ANSWER THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IT LATER.
WE'LL GET TO IT.
WE'RE DOING QUARTERBACKS LATER
AND PROP BETS, BOTH OF WHICH
INVOLVE QUARTERBACKS.
THE QUARTERBACK SECTION INVOLVES
QUARTERBACKS AND THE PROP BETS
HAS A QUARTERBACK SECTION.
FOR ME, YES, MALIK WILSON IS THE
ANSWER.
I LOVE THE WAY YOU DESIGNED THAT
TRADE BECAUSE, LISTEN, I -- I'M
FROM CHARLOTTE.
I STILL GET THE ALERTS FROM THE
CHARLOTTE OBSERVER EVERY DAY.
THEY'RE STILL DEBATING WHAT
THEY'LL DO.
IT'S BEEN HIGH CONTROVERSY,
ESPECIALLY FOR A GUY LIKE MATT
RHULE WHO IS TRYING TO SAVE HIS
JOB.
THEY SAID THEY WILL START WITH
DONALD, BUT IF THEY MAKE A
DECISION ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT THAT
MALIK WILLIS IS OUR GUY AND THEN
ON THURSDAY THE FALCONS DECIDE,
HEY, WE'RE TAKING HIM.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS TO GET
HIM.
THEY'LL BE SITTING IN NO MAN'S
LAND UNLESS THEY REALLY LOVE
KENNY PICKETT.
THAT PART OF IT, THAT
GAMESMANSHIP, THAT
COMPETITIVENESS GOES A LONG WAY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST BEATING
OUT A TEAM.
IT'S NOT LIKE IF THE RAMS GOT
SOMEBODY THE COWBOYS WANT.
THIS IS DIVISION RIVALS, LIKE
THE BATTLE FOR I-85, THESE TEAMS
DON'T LIKE EACH OTHER.
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT,
ESPECIALLY LIKE -- LET'S FAST
FORWARD TEN YEARS AND MALIK
WILLIS IS A FRANCHISE
QUARTERBACK.
THEY JUMPED AHEAD ONE SPOT TO
GET HIM.
YOU'RE GOING TO FEEL LIKE TRASH.
>> YEAH.
IT'S ALL ANYBODY WILL TALK ABOUT
FOR ALL TEN OF THOSE YEARS WHEN
THOSE TEAMS PLAY EACH OTHER.
FOR PEOPLE WHO THINK THIS COST
MIGHT BE SIGNIFICANT, YOU HAVE
TO TAKE INTO CONTEXT WHO THEY'RE
JUMPING, WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING.
GIANTS FANS ARE PROBABLY LIKE WE
DON'T WANT TO MOVE FROM FIVE, WE
NEED A FRANCHISE TACKLE.
IF SOMEBODY IS SWAPPING WITH YOU
FOR A QUARTERBACK, YOU'RE STILL
GETTING 7, GETTING TO PICK AT 8,
AND YOU HAVE THE EXTRA SECOND
ROUNDER.
YOU WILL BE SITTING REAL PRETTY
BECAUSE OF JOE SHANE'S
MANEUVERABILITY HERE.
>> ONE MORE HERE BEFORE WE GET
TO THE COMMENT SECTION.
LET'S LOOK AT -- ONE THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE CREATIVE IN THE
SENSE IT'S NOT THE SPLASHY FIRST
ROUND MOVE.
THIS IS A BIT OF A RIVAL TRADE.
WHEN YOU'RE A SEATTLE TEAM THAT
MIGHT BE LOOKING TO REBUILD, YOU
NEED TO TAKE EVERY PHONE CALL
YOU CAN GET.
THE NINERS WILL GO UP TO 41.
THEY'LL SURRENDER 61, 93, 134.
FELDER, THEY NEED A SAFETY, MAN.
THIS IS A GOOD FOOTBALL TEAM.
THIS IS A TEAM CLOSE TO GETTING
TO A SUPER BOWL.
THEY LOST SOME PLAYERS IN FREE
AGENCY.
THEY MADE SOME SAVVY MOVES.
YOU LOOK AT THE BACK END OF
THEIR DEFENSIVE BACKFIELD, I
LOVE JAQUAN BRISKER AT 43.
GO UP AND GET AN INSTANT IMPACT
PLAYER.
>> I LOVE HIM.
LIKE, I AM HAVING SUCH A HARD
TIME WITH THE SAFETIES IN THIS
DRAFT.
FOR ALL THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
QUARTERBACKS AND IS THIS A GOOD
TACKLE DRAFT, WHATEVER, THIS IS
A REALLY GOOD SAFETY DRAFT.
WE SHOULD BE TALKING MORE ABOUT
IT.
I THINK IT'S, ONE, WE'RE BEING
ABUSED BY THE WAY FOOTBALL IS
SHOT ON CAMERA.
YOU HAVE TO GO SO FAR TO FIND
PLAYS WHERE THE SAFETY IS IN
PLAY ALL THE TIME.
IF HAMILTON IS YOUR FAVORITE
SAFETY, COOKS IS MY FAVORITE
SAFETY, HILL IS MY FAVORITE
PLAYER TO TALK ABOUT BRISKER IS
THE GUY I WANT BACK-TO-BACK IN A
BAR.
THAT'S THE GUY I WANT
BACK-TO-BACK -- MAYBE SOMEBODY
DID SOMETHING WILD AND POURED A
DRINK ON SOMEONE'S GIRLFRIEND'S
HEAD, BUT BRISKER WILL STAND
BACK-TO-BACK WITH YOU AND YOU
GUYS WILL WHACK OUTALK OUT OF T
ALIVE.
LEASE A BRUISER, HE'S LIKE A
BROAD STREET BULLY.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT HIM.
WATCHING THE WAY HE PLAYED
THROUGH INJURY, PLAYED THROUGH
FATIGUE AND STILL WAS JUST LIKE,
I GOT TO DO THIS FOR MY TEAM.
WHAT DOES SAMMY SOSA SAY?
I DO THIS FOR MY TEAM, I DO THIS
FOR MY FAMILY.
I LOVE THIS TRADE.
ANYBODY THAT MOVES UP TO GET
BRISKER, I'M IN FOR IT.
>> LET'S LOOK AT THE COMMENTS.
THEY'RE JUMPING OFF.
M. KENT SAID DO THE TITANS TRADE
UP OR DOWN?
I THINK WHEN I LOOK AT THE
TITANS, THEY COULD USE OFFENSIVE
LINE HELP, THEY'RE SITTING IN
THE BACK END OF ROUND ONE.
THE QUESTION IS, DO THEY HAVE TO
JUMP AN ARIZONA FOR ONE OF THESE
TOP GUARDS?
DO THEY HAVE TO GET A TACKLE?
THAT'S GOING TO BE A FASCINATING
SITUATION FOR THEM.
WILL THEY MAKE A COLOSSAL MOVE
TO GET ONE OF THE BIG THREE
BEFORE THEY'RE ALL GONE?
STILLER ANTHONY SAID DO THE
BILLS MAKE A MOVE FOR ONE OF
THESE TOP CORNERS?
MAYBE SAUCE OR STINGLEY?
WHAT ABOUT TRENT McDUFFY FOR
THEM OR DO YOU LIKE THE IDEA OF
GOING WAY, WAY UP FOR SAUCE OR
STINGLEY?
>> I'M NEVER GOING TO SAY NO TO
GOING UP TO GET A DEFENSIVE
BACK, I THINK IF YOU GET DUFFY
LATER, THAT HELPS YOU.
HE'S SCHEMED VERSATILE.
HE CAN PLAY ZONE, PLAY MAN, PLAY
PRESS, PLAY OFF.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO HELP YOU
IN THE RUN GAME AS WELL.
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR.
I WANT SOMEONE THAT CAN DO A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS A TEAM, WE
KNOW HOW THEY LIKE TO PLAY.
THEY DO LIKE TO PLAY MAN AND
THAT SHOW PRESS.
THE BIG KEY HERE IS FINDING A
GUY -- IF YOU GET A GUY THAT CAN
DO A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT THINGS,
GET HIM.
THAT'S THE KEY.
>> I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
WE'LL DO ONE MORE FROM THE
COMMENTS HERE BEFORE WE GET INTO
OUR QUARTERBACK BREAKDOWN.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS FROM FLY 1313.
LIONS SHOULD TAKE THIBODEAUX OR
TRADE DOWN.
THE LIONS ARE ALWAYS IN A BAD
SPOT LIKE THE ACUNA YEAR.
I THINK YOUR FIRST POINT IS MORE
IMPORTANT.
YOU'RE NOT IN A BAD SPOT BECAUSE
AT TWO, YOU CAN GET KAYVON
THIBODEAUX.
THERE'S NOTHING TO FEAR.
>> HE'S GOOD.
THIS GUY IS AMAZING.
HE'S SO GOOD.
IF YOU GET HIM, GET HIM.
THIS COULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY
WHERE YOU'RE LIKE YOU GET TO
LAUGH AT THE JAGS,
REALISTICALLY.
OH, LOOK WHO WE GOT AND YOU GUYS
HAD -- I THINK THE JAGUARS ARE
IN THE MOST HIGH-PRESSURE
SITUATION IN THE DRAFT.
THE PLAYER THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS
THEY LIKE IS AIDAN HUTCHINSON.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET HIM NUMBER
ONE OVERALL.
BUT THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PICK ANY OF THE 300 OR SOMETHING
PLAYERS THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
WHEN YOU MISS AT THAT ONE SPOT,
YOU CAN'T SAY WE WANTED TO GET
THIS OTHER GUY SO WE TOOK THIS
OTHER GUY.
YOU HAVE THE CHOICE TO MAKE THE
DECISION.
IF YOU PASS OVER THIBODEAUX, YOU
PASS HIM OVER, SOMEBODY ELSE
GETS HIM AND HE BECOMES A
SUPERSTAR, WHO MADE THE MISTAKE?
YOU.
>> MAN.
IT'S CRAZY TO THINK ABOUT.
HONESTLY, THE CLOSER WE GET TO
THE DRAFT, IT COULD BE REALITY.
I SAW IN THE COMMENT SECTION
JUMPING OFF ABOUT THE PACKERS.
THEY PICK AT 22 AND 28.
I THINK THEY CAN MOVE UP AND GET
A WIDE RECEIVER.
>> FELDER, WOULD YOU SAY --
>> TIME OUT.
TIME OUT.
DO THEY HAVE TO MOVE UP TO GET A
WIDE RECEIVER?
>> THAT'S WHERE I'M GOING WITH
IT.
>> GETTING A WIDE RECEIVER AT 22
OR 28, OR AT 22 AND 28, THAT'S
MORE THAN THEY WOULD HAVE DONE
ALREADY FOR AARON RODGERS,
RIGHT?
>> YES.
DO YOU THINK A CHRISTIAN WATSON
WILL BE THERE?
I DON'T THINK CHRIS OLAVE WILL
BE THERE?
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE IF THEY WANT
TO GO UP FOR A JAMESON WILLIAMS
AS WE SAW IN OUR EARLIER MOCK
SITUATION.
LET'S GET INTO THE QUARTERBACKS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TIME FOR THE
QUARTERBACKS.
WE HAVE QUARTERBACK TALK, DRAFT
PROP TALK.
WE WILL BREAK DOWN THE AFC SOUTH
AS WELL.
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS, WHETHER
IT'S PACKERS, THROW IT IN THE
COMMENT SECTION.
LET'S GET INTO THE QUARTERBACKS.
WE HAVE TO START WITH THE
PROJECTED TOP PICKS.
WE'LL DO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TIERS TODAY.
THE ATHLETIC GUYS, BIG-ARM
POCKET PASSERS.
WE HAVE TO START WITH THE BIG
TWO.
WE KNOW THEY'RE GOING IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
THEY COULD GO IN THE TOP TEN AT
THIS POINT.
IT'S BEEN A HUGE CLIMB.
WE'LL START WITH MALIK WILLIS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT MALIK WILLIS,
TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER, FOR A
TEAM LIKE ATLANTA TO JUMP THE
PANTHERS TO GET HIM.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, I
STRUGGLED COMING UP WITH A
PLAYER COMPARISON FOR HIM.
HE'S A UNIQUE PLAYER.
HE OBVIOUSLY IS MOBILE AND A
GOOD RUNNER, BUT HE'S NOT A
LAMAR JACKSON TYPE OF RUNNER.
HE HAS A HOWITZER OF AN ARM.
I THOUGHT IN THIS ERA OF THE
NFL, KORDELL STEWART WOULD BE A
BETTER KIND OF PLAYER.
THAT'S A COMPLIMENT, NOT AN
INSULT TO WILLIS' GAME.
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN FROM MALIK
WILLIS, GOING FROM AUBURN, TO
LIBERTY, BUT THE PROJECTED TOP
TEN PICK HE IS NOW.
>> WHEN YOU GO BACK TO THE
COMPS, IF I'M GOING TO COMP,
HE'S LIKE GREAT VALUE, EQUATE,
VICK, WHO GOT TO PLAY IN THIS
ERA VERSUS THE PRO STYLE ERA.
WHERE BIG ARM -- VICK HAD A HUGE
ARM.
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT THIS.
VICK HAD A MASSIVE ARM.
IF MICHAEL VICK PLAYED TODAY,
PEOPLE WOULD BE LIKE WOW, THIS
IS INSANE.
UNREAL.
THE ARM IS THE PART I'M
COMPARING TO VICK, NOT THE LEGS.
THE LEGS PART IS MORE --
GOODNESS, HE'S LIKE JEFF GARCIA.
IF JEFF GARCIA AND MICHAEL VICK
HAD A KID, HE IS SLIPPERY ENOUGH
TO BE A PROBLEM.
HE'S NOT STEVE YOUNG, NOT VICK,
NOT JACKSON.
TO ME, THAT NEXT LEVEL OF
SLIPPERY IS JEFF GARCIA.
I WOULD THROW HIM INTO THE MIX.
BUT JEFF GARCIA HAD A LITTLE PEA
SHOOTER.
THIS GUY HAS THAT VICK, HUGE ARM
TO GET THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD.
THE BIG THING WITH MALIK WILSON,
WHY I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE THE
FIRST QUARTERBACK OFF THE BOARD,
HIS ABILITY TO ALWAYS KEEP HIS
EYES DOWNFIELD.
THAT ABILITY TO TRACK IS
IMPORTANT.
WE SEE GUYS LIKE RUSSELL WILSON
HAVE THAT ABILITY.
ROETHLISBERGER IS ANOTHER GUY --
NOT SUPER MOBILE BUT SUPER BIG
AND ABILITY TO EVADE AND THEN
GET HIS EYES BACK DOWNFIELD AND
MAKE PLAYS.
HE HAS THAT QUALITY OF ALWAYS
KNOWING WHERE HIS GUYS WILL COME
OPEN.
I LOVE THE PLAY AGAINST VIRGINIA
TECH FROM TWO SEASONS AGO, HE
SPINS OUT TO EVADE, DROPS A DIME
ON THE ONE-YARD LINE AND JUST
KEEPS HIM IN BOUNDS TO MAKE A
PLAY.
FOR ME, THAT'S WHY I THINK HE'S
THE BEST QUARTERBACK IN THE
GROUP.
SUPER TALENTED BY ALL ACCOUNTS.
YOU COULD TALK TO ME ABOUT THIS,
YOU WERE AT THE COMBINE, YOU
TALKED TO FOLKS WHO TALKED TO
HIM, YOU WERE ABLE TO SEE WHAT
HE CAN DO.
PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
HE'S GOT AN INFECTIOUS
PERSONALITY.
JUST -- I THINK PUTTING ALL
THOSE THINGS TOGETHER, THEY PUT
HIM IN PRIME POSITION HERE.
>> I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT,
WHAT YOU DO OFF THE CAMERA, THE
BOARDWALK, BEING THE FACE OF THE
FRANCHISE.
THE GUY THAT AFTER EVERY LOSS
HAS TO BE ON THE PODIUM
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
WENT WRONG.
MALIK WILLIS IS THAT KIND OF
PERSON THAT YOU CAN PUT THAT
LEVEL OF TRUST IN.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
COMPLIMENT YOU CAN GIVE ANY
PLAYER BEFORE THE NFL DRAFT.
IT'S WHAT GOT MALIK WILLIS FROM
GREAT ATHLETE, HUGE ARM,
OBVIOUSLY ALL THE TALENT IN THE
WORLD TO BONAFIED TOP TEN PICK,
WE BELIEVE IN HIM AS THE FUTURE
OF OUR FRANCHISE, THAT'S HOW HE
WILL BE DRAFTED.
STARTS AT 2 WITH THE LIONS,
COULD BE THE PANTHERS AT 6, AND
THEN REAL INTERESTING AFTER
THAT.
SPEAKING OF GETTING INTERESTING,
KENNY PICKETT, THE OTHER TOP
FLIGHT QUARTERBACK IN THE DRAFT,
HONESTLY, COULDN'T BE MORE
OPPOSITE IN THE KIND OF MOLD OF
THE PROSPECT HE IS.
HE'S NOT JUST THIS SLOW-FOOTED
POCKET PASSER.
HE CAN MOVE.
BUT KENNY PICKETT IS MORE OF THE
PINPOINT WINDOW THROWER, GET THE
BALL OUT.
ACCURATE.
OBVIOUSLY CAN MOVE AND
MANIPULATE THE POCKET AT TIMES,
HIS HIGHS REMIND ME OF DEREK
CARR.
DEREK CARR IS A REALLY GOOD
QUARTERBACK IN THE NFL RIGHT NOW
THAT FOR A SECOND ROUND PICK HAS
EXCEEDED EXPECTATIONS BY A MILE.
FOR KENNY PICKETT, HE PLAYS IN A
SIMILAR STYLE.
HAS A SIMILAR BODY TYPE AND
ATHLETICISM MOLD.
PEOPLE WILL LOVE HIS ABILITY TO
COME IN AND RUN THE OFFENSE
RIGHT AWAY.
THAT HIGH FLOOR PLAYER.
THAT'S WHY WHEN IT'S ALL SAID
AND DONE, HE'S A LOCK TO GO IN
THE TOP 20.
IT WOULDN'T BE SHOCKING TO ME IF
SOMEBODY MOVED INTO THE TOP 15
TO GET HIM.
THIS IS ONE WHO HAS REALLY
DEVELOPED AT PITT.
HE'S AN OLDER PROSPECT.
I THINK HE'LL BE A 24-YEAR-OLD
ROOKIE, BUT THE STEPS HE'S TAKEN
FROM 2020/2021 IS MONUMENTAL.
>> WATCHING HIS ABILITY TO GO
FROM -- THIS IS A GUY HE MIGHT
HAVE RAN MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COLLEGE FOOTBALL PLAYER IN HIS
COLLEGE CAREER WHEN THEY HAD TO
RUN TO THE SIDELINE EVERY PLAY
TO GET THE PLAY, BRING THE PLAY
IN, DO THE HUDDLE, RUN BACK TO
THE SIDELINE TO GET THE PLAY.
IT WAS VERY HIGH SCHOOL HARRY
SOME OF THE THINGS HE WAS DOING.
THE COOL THING ABOUT HIM, HIS
ABILITY TO MAKE ANTICIPATORY
THROWS, AND HE'S SOMEONE -- I
SAID THIS BEFORE, BUT HE LOOKS
LIKE MATT RYAN, BUT PLAYS MORE
LIKE RUSSELL WILSON.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM PUTTING THIS
ON WAX FOR EVERYBODY TO HEAR.
HE IS THE FASTEST PLAYER IN THE
COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING
TO THE SIDELINES.
THERE'S NO ONE FASTER THAN KENNY
PICKETT WHEN IT COMES TIME TO
GET TO THE SIDELINES.
HE WILL BEAT YOUR LINEBACKER, HE
WILL BEAT YOUR SAFETY, HE'LL
BEAT YOUR CORNER.
HE'LL GET TO THE SIDELINES IN A
HURRY BECAUSE HE UNDERSTANDS HOW
TO PROTECT HIMSELF.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE FAKE
SLIDE AND THE WHOLE DEAL.
THE REALITY OF IT WITH HIM IS
THAT HE UNDERSTANDS THE BEST
THING I CAN DO IS BE IN THE
GAME.
IF I HAVE TO MAKE SURE I'M
PROTECTING MYSELF, I'M STAYING
IN THE GAME.
AND HE'S PLAYING IN AN NFL
SYSTEM.
THERE'S NO TWO WAYS ABOUT THAT.
HE'S PLAYING IN AN NFL SYSTEM.
HE'S PLAYING FOR AN NFL
OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO GET THERE.
UNDERSTANDS WHEN THE GUYS COME
OPEN.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHEN TO MAKE
THOSE THROWS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
FOLKS WILL APPRECIATE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
APPRECIATE ABOUT HIM BECAUSE
WATCHING HIM PLAY IS LIKE
PUTTING ON ESSENTIALLY A CLINIC.
OKAY.
I HAVE A FOUR -- THERE'S FOUR
GUYS IN THIS ROUTE.
HE'S NOT OPEN RIGHT NOW.
HE'S NOT OPEN.
OH.
NO.
WHAT DO I HAVE TO DO?
GOT IT.
I HAVE TO WAIT FOR THIS GUY TO
CLEAR.
NOW I CAN HIT HIM.
THAT'S WHY FOR ME HE BECOMES
VALUABLE AS AN ASSET TO YOUR
FRANCHISE, HE UNDERSTANDS
COVERAGES AND WHEN GUYS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE OPEN, WHICH GOES
BACK TO OUR JAMESON WILLIAM
POINT ABOUT TEMPOING ROUTES AND
HOW THINGS WORK.
I THINK IT'S THE SAME THING.
>> YOU SEE THE COMMENT THERE WHO
SAYS PICKETT REMINDS ME OF
DALTON WHO WILL HAVE A GOOD
CAREER BUT NOT GREAT AND CAN
CARRY A TEAM.
FAIR COMMENT.
PICKETT IS NOT IN THE MOLD OF
SOME OF THE PROSPECTS WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS, IT'S THE OLD
TRACTOR TRAILER AND TRAILER
SITUATION.
ARE YOU GOING TO DRIVE THE TEAM
OR ARE YOU ALONG FOR THE RIDE?
SOMETIMES THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT.
THAT WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR KENNY
PICKETT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF QUARTERBACKS TO
GO THROUGH.
LET'S GO REALLY IN A SENSE TO A
DIFFERENT TIER.
THIS IS OUR BIG ARM QUARTERBACKS
HERE.
WE WILL START WITH SAM HOWELL,
MAYBE NOT THE BIGGEST
QUARTERBACK, BUT THE ARM IS
REAL.
THE VELOCITY IS SOME OF THE
FASTEST THEY SAW AT THE COMBINE.
AT THE SENIOR BOWL, HE HAD AN UP
AND DOWN THROWING PERFORMANCE,
BUT SAM HOWELL, YOU NERVE HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THE ARM STRENGTH
OF HIM.
WE SEEN HIM MAKE PLAYS WITH HIS
LEGS.
THIS YEAR IT FELT LIKE HE HAD TO
PLAY HERO BALL.
PLAYS BREAKING DOWN.
LOOKING TO MAKE THAT PLAY WITH
HIS LEGS.
ONCE AGAIN, A LOT OF THAT IS THE
TALENT AROUND HIM.
FOR ME, THIS IS SOMETHING I
PROJECT TO GO MORE IN THE TOP 75
OF THE DRAFT, NOT THE FIRST
ROUND OF THE DRAFT.
WHERE DO YOU SEE SAM HOWELL'S
NFL CAREER PROJECTION AND WHAT
HE DOES BEST RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M WITH YOU.
I THINK HE'S A GUY WHO WILL END
UP ON DAY TWO.
THE COOL THING FOR HIM, AND FOR
FOLKS WHO DON'T KNOW, HE
COMMITTED TO FLORIDA STATE.
FLORIDA STATE GOES THROUGH
TURMOIL, HE DECIDES TO STAY AT
HOME.
HE'S NOT FROM CHARLOTTE, DON'T
GET IT TWISTED.
HE'S FROM UNION COUNTY.
SUN VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL, THAT'S
NOT IN CHARLOTTE.
HE IS SOMEONE -- IT'S
INTERESTING THAT YOU HAD TO
MENTION HE HAD TO PLAY HERO BALL
IN 2021, BUT HE'S ABLE TO DO
THAT.
HE'S ABLE TO BREAK TACKLES AND
MAKE PLAYS.
I THOUGHT ABOUT PUTTING HIM INTO
THE ATHLETICISM CATEGORY, BUT
HIS ARM IS SO GOOD.
HE GETS TAGGED BY A GUY, DON'T
WORRY, I'M SCORING.
GIVING PEOPLE THE BUSINESS AND
LETTING THEM KNOW ABOUT IT.
HE'S SUPER TALENTED.
THE QUESTION BECOMES CAN HE
THROW BETWEEN THE HASH MARKS?
CAN HE THROW INTO THE INTERIOR
OF THE FIELD?
I KNOW WE'LL TALK CARSON STRONG
AS WELL.
SO MUCH OF HIS WORK WAS VERTICAL
TO THE EDGES.
THAT'S WHERE YOU MAKE
HIGHLIGHTS, BUT IN BETWEEN THE
HASHES IS WHERE YOU MAKE FIRST
DOWNS, FIRST DOWNS LEAD TO
TOUCHDOWNS.
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO SEE HIM
IMPROVE.
AS YOU MENTIONED THE HERO BALL,
THIS GUY RAN FOR ALMOST 900
YARDS.
THIS GUY RAN FOR A LOT OF YARDS
A YEAR AGO.
HE'S WILLING TO DO IT.
THAT INCLUDES THE SACKS.
IF YOU TAKE THE SACKS OUT, HE
PROBABLY RAN FOR 1,000 YARDS.
HE'S AMAZING AT BEING TOUGH TO
WIN AT THE POINT, TO DO THOSE
THINGS, WHICH GIVES HIM THE
ABILITY, AND I THINK FOR ME, I
THINK ON DAY TWO, HE BECOMES
SOMEONE THAT, HEY, WE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT HIM.
WE LIKE HIM.
WE JUST HAVE TO TEACH HIM HOW TO
DO THESE THINGS THAT THEY ARE
NOT TEACHING ON COLLEGE OFFENSES
RIGHT NOW.
PHIL LONGO DIDN'T IMPART HIM
WITH THESE SKILLS.
IF WE CAN TEACH HIM TO DO THAT,
MAYBE IT'S AN ALEX SMITH T-TYPE
SITUATION.
ONCE HE LEARNED FOOTBALL, HE GOT
BETTER.
HE'S IN THAT SAME CAMP, YOU HAVE
TO ASK HIM TO DO MORE.
ALL HE HAD TO DO IN COLLEGE TO
WIN WAS THROW THE BALL DEEP AND
R
RUN.
>> THE QUESTION IS, CAN HE LEARN
TO PAPER CUT A DEFENSE?
THE 8 TO 10-YARD, 8 TO 15-YARD
THROWS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELDS THAT KEEP YOU ON THE
FIELD, KEEP THE DEFENSE ON THE
FIELD, TIRE THEM OUT AND SUSTAIN
DRIVES AT THE NFL.
MOST OF THE TIME THAT'S THE NFL
GAME.
I THINK HOWELL HAS A CHANCE TO
IMPROVE THAT.
YOU SEE THE COMMENT, SAM HOWELL
IS RUSSELL WILSON.
I GET AWAY FROM COMPS THAT ARE
SUPER RICH.
I THINK HE'S CASE KEENUM WITH A
STRONGER ARM.
CASE KEENUM HAS COME IN, STARTED
IN SPURTS AND IGNITED HIS TEAM
TO WIN IN BIG SPOTS.
I THINK HOWELL PLAYS WITH THAT
FIERY ENERGY THAT I LOVE.
I SAW SOMEBODY CONNECT HIM TO
THE TITANS.
I THINK THAT'S A TREMENDOUS FIT
BEHIND TANNEHILL.
LET'S KEEP THIS MOVING --
>> AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY THE
OFFENSE SO MUCH.
>> EXACTLY.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE RUN-HEAVY
APPROACH THEY HAVE.
OUR NEXT BIG ARM QUARTERBACK IS
CARSON STRONG.
HE'S NOT GOING TO MOVE LIKE THE
THREE GUYS WE TALKED ABOUT,
WILLIS, PICKETT, SAM HOWELL.
FELDER, THIS GUY HAS A HOWITZER,
HE HAS A BAZOOKA.
YOU WATCH THE NEVADA OFFENSE
WITH DUBDUBBS AND TURNER, THEY E
NOT AFRAID TO GET FORWARD.
CARSON STRONG, THE KNEE INJURY
IN THE PAST HAS BEEN A CONCERN
FOR THE TEAMS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE CHECKED OUT
OKAY.
HE'S A CLASSIC DROP BACK, LET ME
HIT ALL THREE LEVELS OF THE
FIELD, BUT I LIKE THESE 20-PLUS
YARD THROWS.
HE'S A LITTLE OLD SCHOOL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF CARSON
STRONG WHO HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
FOR THAT NEVADA PROGRAM?
>> I LOVED WATCHING HIM PLAY THE
LAST COUPLE OF SEASONS.
HE WAS ONE OF MY HIDDEN GEMS OF
JUST, WATCH THIS GUY THROW THE
BALL.
HE'S GOING TO LAUNCH IT.
HE STILL HAS A PRETTY TIGHT
RELEASE, WHICH I LIKE IT DOESN'T
TAKE HIM HOURS.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO
TAKES HOURS TO THROW THE
FOOTBALL.
I LOVE THAT PART OF HIS GAME.
CARSON STRONG -- ARE YOU GOING
TO TELL ME JOHN ELWAY IS NOT
SITTING THERE LIKE, MAN, THIS
GUY, THIS COULD BE MY GUY.
HE COULD BE THE GUY.
THERE'S GOING TO BE OLD-SCHOOL
FOLKS WHO LOVE THE IDEA OF DROP
BACK THROW FAR THAT WILL FALL IN
LOVE WITH HIM.
I DON'T THINK THEY FALL IN LOVE
WITH HIM TO THE TUNE OF THE
FIRST ROUND, WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE FLIRTED WITH IN THE FIRST
HALF OF THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL
SEASON AND FELL OFF AS WE
WATCHED THINGS HAPPEN.
CARSON STRONG, MAN, BIG TREE
FALL HARD.
THIS GUY WILL GO BACK THERE,
THROW IT AS FAR AS HE CAN.
HE WILL BE -- THE OTHER PART IS,
HE'S REMARKABLY ACCURATE IN HIS
DEEP THROWS.
THAT'S A TESTAMENT TO SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT JUST, YOU KNOW,
CLOSING THEIR EYES AND WINGING
IT.
IT'S SOMEONE WHO UNDERSTANDS THE
COMPLEX CALCULATIONS THAT IT
TAKES TO PUT THE BALL ON YOUR
WIDE RECEIVER, WEAR THE
DEFENSIVE BACK IS, THROW THEM TO
THE SIDE IF THEY'RE OPEN, THROW
THEM TO THE SIDELINE IF YOU NEED
TO GET THEM OPEN.
HE DOES ALL THOSE THINGS WELL.
I THINK HE'S PROBABLY A DAY TWO
GUY.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOMEONE WHO JUST -- A COACH THAT
GETS ENAMORED WITH THE IDEA OF I
CAN FIX HIM.
YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS ON
"TAPE DON'T LIE."
A SCOUT, COACH, COORDINATOR THAT
IS LIKE I CAN GET HIM TO WHERE I
NEED HIM TO BE.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO TEACH
KENNY PICKETT TO THROW THE BALL
AS FAR AS CARSON STRONG.
SO, IF THAT'S THE THING YOU
REALLY LIKE, GET HIM NOW.
YOU THINK YOU CAN TEACH HIM TO
DO SOME OF THE OTHER LITTLE
THINGS RIGHT.
>> TO ME, HE'S IN THE MOLD OF A
CHAD HENNE, PEOPLE MIGHT LAUGH
AT ME WHEN THEY HEAR THAT NAME.
HENNE HAS BEEN IN THE NFL FOR BH
ABOUT 14 YEARS.
IF STRONG IS IN THE NFL FOR 14
YEARS, EEHE'LL BE DOING JUST FI.
THIS ONE SAYS FELDER'S BEARD
LOOKING STRONG.
I PROJECT CARSON STRONG AS A TOP
100 PICK AND A LONG-TERM BACKUP,
IF YOU WANT HIM TO BE YOUR
FRANCHISE SAVIOR, YOU'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE
DISAPPOINTED.
STRONG IS DREW BLEDSOE, FELDER,
MORE OF A RICH COMP THAN ME, BUT
I THINK THAT PLAY STYLE HITS.
I LIKE IT.
WAY TO GET IN ON THE PLAYER
COMPARISON GAME.
WE HAVE A LOADED SHOW.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THIS MOVING.
IT'S TIME FOR A LITTLE
ATHLETICISM AT THE QUARTERBACK
POSITION.
WE KNOW MALIK WILLIS HAS IT,
PICKETT AND HOWELL HAVE IT, BUT
THESE GUYS, IT'S THEIR CALLING
CARD.
LET'S START WITH MATT CORRAL.
A RHYTHM THROWER IN MY EYES.
YOU GET HIM MOVING IN THE
OFFENSE, YES, A LOT OF IT IN
THAT OLE MISS OFFENSE IS FIRST
READ.
IF IT'S THERE, I'LL LET IT RIP.
IF IT'S NOT, I'LL RUN.
YOU DON'T WANT TO USE THAT AS AN
INSULT, A LOT OF COLLEGE
QUARTERBACKS PLAY IN THAT
OFFENSE AND A LOT IN THE NFL
PLAY WITH THAT OFFENSE.
CORRAL MAY HAVE THE HIGHEST
CEILING OF ANY QUARTERBACK NOT
IN THE FIRST TWO WE DID IN THE
SHOW.
THE QUESTION IS WITH HIS
RUNNING, CAN THAT BODY TYPE STAY
HEALTHY?
CAN HE LIMIT THE RISK HE TAKES?
WITH CORRAL ON TAPE, SOMETIMES
YOU'RE LIKE I LOVE YOUR
GUNSLINGER MENTALITY, BUT I
THINK HE'S A LITTLE WILD WITH
THE FOOTBALL SOMETIMES.
>> HE HAS A TREMENDOUS ARM AND
HE BELIEVES IN THAT ARM IN A BIG
WAY.
SO, BECAUSE HE CAN DO THAT --
THIS IS GOING BACK TO HIGH
SCHOOL.
I REMEMBER WATCHING HIM IN
OREGON.
WATCHING HIM JUST BEING, NO, I
CAN FIT IT IN.
YOU SEE IT THERE.
LOOK AT THAT.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE MADE THAT
THROW.
THREE GUYS WERE AROUND HIM.
DON'T MAKE THAT THROW, BUT HE
DOES IT BECAUSE HE KNOWS HE CAN.
IF HE MAKES IT 65% OF THE TIME,
YOU'LL BE HAPPY WITH IT.
THAT'S THE QUESTION MARK ABOUT
MATT CORRAL.
SUPER TALENTED.
SUPER ATHLETIC.
DIDN'T REALIZE HOW ATHLETIC HE
WAS UNTIL HE GOT TO OLE MISS.
I WILL KICK ANOTHER ONE BACK TO
YOU.
I WILL GO DESMOND RIDDER.
HE'S ONE THAT -- MATT CORRAL MAY
THROW PEOPLE FOR A LOOP BECAUSE
HE'S A PASSER, BUT DESMOND
RIDDER IS THE ATHLETIC QB OF
THIS CLASS FOR BETTER OR FOR
WORSE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIM, HE'S
SOMEONE -- I THINK THE COACHING
IS THE NEXT THING FOR HIM.
I THINK HE MAKES GOOD LAYERED
THROWS.
I THINK HE HAS THE ABILITY TO
OBVIOUSLY BEAT YOU WITH HIS
LEGS.
I THINK THE KEY FOR HIM IS ALL
GOING TO BE BETWEEN THE EARS.
I THINK HE CAN DO EVERYTHING YOU
WANT A QUARTERBACK TO DO.
IT'S JUST MATTER OF HIM MANAGING
HIS OWN EMOTIONS AND
FRUSTRATION.
>> I THINK SO, TOO.
WITH RIDDER, YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK
ATTESTING TESTING NUMBERS, YOU
WANT HIM TO PLAY MORE LIKE AN
ATHLETE AND OPEN UP SOME OF THE
PASSING WINDOWS HE STRUGGLES
WITH AT TIMES.
RIDDER HAS ALL THE NECESSARY
TALENT TO BE A STARTING
QUARTERBACK.
HE HAS THE BODY TYPE, THE ARM,
ATHLETICISM.
THE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
OFFENSE.
THE BIGGEST THING FOR ME THAT
GOES BACK TO WHAT YOU SAID, HE
NEEDS TO PLAY FASTER.
HE'S A FOUR-YEAR STARTER AND THE
PLAY CLOCK HAS NOT GOTTEN TO
WHERE YOU EXPECT IT TO BE AFTER
STARTING FOR FOUR YEARS, PLAYED
FOR A PROGRAM IN CINCINNATI WHO
WAS IN THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL
PLAYOFF.
THEY PLAYED IN SOME BIG FOOTBALL
GAMES AND AT A HIGH LEVEL.
THERE'S TIMES WHERE HE'S A STEP
SLOW.
MAYBE SOME OF IT IS HIS RELEASE.
SOME OF IT IS ALSO JUST
DIAGNOSING AND PLAYING AT A
CERTAIN SPEED WHERE HE'S
ALLOWING DEFENDERS TO SEE
THINGS.
RIDDER WILL GET DRAFTED IN THE
TOP 50 AND DRAFTED AS A FUTURE
STARTER, THE QUESTION IS CAN A
COACHING STAFF BUILD THE RIGHT
OFFENSE FOR HIM THAT DISPLAYS
MORE OF THAT ATHLETICISM AS THE
PASSING GAME SPEEDS UP.
>> I LOVE THAT ASSESSMENT.
I THINK THE KEY FOR ME IS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE OFFENSE
IS ASKING OF YOU AND HOW TO DO
IT.
ANOTHER GUY WE HAVE IN THE
CATEGORY, SKYLAR THOMPSON.
I THINK HE IS SUPER ATHLETIC.
PEOPLE DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE HIS
ATHLETICISM BECAUSE HE PLAYED AT
KANSAS STATE.
HE'S A LITTLE BIT WILEY,
SLIPPERY.
HE FINDS A WAY TO STEAL YARDS.
IF I WAS GOING TO DO A COMP,
CONNER SHAW.
>> NICE.
BUT HE MAKES THROWS.
HE HAS THESE WEIRD GAMES.
I'M DOING THIS WEEK TO WEEK ON
SATURDAYS, JUST WATCHING THIS
BASED ON THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL
WORLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU WATCH
SOME OF THESE WEIRD GAMES WHERE
HE SHOWS UP AND JUST MAKES
THROWS LIKE THIS DOWN THE FIELD
AND YOU'RE LIKE WHEN DID YOU --
WHERE WAS THAT AT THE GAME
BEFORE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S MY FRUSTRATION WITH
SKYLAR THOMPSON.
THERE'S FLASHES WHERE YOU GO,
THE ARM IS THERE.
THE TOUCH THROWS DOWN THE FIELD
ARE THERE, WHY ARE YOU NOT
THROWING THE BALL SOME WEEKS?
THERE'S SOME WEEKS WHERE HE
DOESN'T WANT TO LET THE FOOTBALL
GO.
YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
CRITICIZING A GUY'S GAME.
IS THERE A COACH IN HIS EAR THAT
SAYS WE DON'T CARE WHAT YOU DO
FOR US, JUST DON'T MAKE
MISTAKES.
IF YOU THINK THERE'S A CHANCE OF
A MISTAKE MADE, DO NOT THROW THE
BALL.
LIVE TO MAKE ANOTHER PLAY.
THE NEXT DOWN, THE NEXT DRIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SKYLAR
THOMPSON, A LOT OF TIMES IT WAS
THE NEXT WEEK.
THAT'S SOMETHING TO ME THAT
MAKES HIM ONE OF THE HARDEST
PROJECTIONS OUT OF ALL OF THESE
GUYS.
LIKE YOU SAID, THERE ARE FLASH
PLAYS.
HE WILL GET AN NFL CAMP.
HE'LL GET TO UTILIZE AND SHOW
OFF THAT ARM.
CAN HE HANG ON TO A PRACTICE
SQUAD AND GET A CHANCE TO HANG
ON TO THE LEAGUE?
WE'VE SEEN GLIMPSES OF TALENT TO
SHOW THAT HE CAN.
LET'S GET TO THE COMMENTS BEFORE
WE GO TO THE PINPOINT ACCURACY
GUYS OF THIS DRAFT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
COMMENTS COMING IN.
MATT CORRAL IS THIS YEAR'S MAC
JONES.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF PRAISE.
CORRAL COULD SNEAK INTO ROUND
ONE, BUT WILL HE PLAY WEEK ONE?
BIG ARM 77 SAID CORRAL IS
MARIOTA.
THAT WAS MY PLAYER COMP ON THE
SHOW.
BUT HE'S SMALLER, SO HE NEEDS TO
BE CAREFUL WITH THAT RUNNING.
THAT BODY TYPE CANNOT TAKE THE
SAME HITS.
MARIOTA HAS A COUPLISME INCHES
SOME WEIGHT ON HIM.
WE HAVE THE PINPOINT ACCURACY
QUARTERBACKS.
WE'LL TALK WITH BAILEY ZAPPE, IF
YOU HAVE NOT WATCHED HIM PLAY,
GOOGLE THE PRODUCTION TO SEE THE
INSANE STATS NOT JUST AT WESTERN
KENTUCKY BUT HE TRANSFERRED FROM
HOUSTON BAPTIST.
HE PLAYED WITH JARED STERNS AT
BOTH SCHOOLS AND THREW FOR A
MAMMOTH AMOUNT OF YARDS.
>> OVER 60 TOUCHDOWNS.
UNBELIEVABLE WHAT HE'S ABLE TO
DO.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
YOU SEE IT THERE.
HE'S A RHYTHM THROWER.
HE GETS TO THE TOP OF HIS DROP,
TAKES A BEAT, LETS IT GO.
HE KNOWS WHERE THE GUY WILL COME
OPEN, WHEN HE'S SUPPOSED TO AND
PUTS THE BALL ON HIM.
WE TALKED ABOUT SAM HOWELL NOT
THROWING TO THE INTERIOR, THIS
GUY LOVES TO EAT UP THE INTERIOR
WITH SLANTS, DIGS, CROSSES.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHEN AND WHERE
GUYS WILL COME OPEN.
WHAT A REMARKABLE EXPERIMENT
BRINGING OVER A STAFF AND A
QUARTERBACK, WIDE RECEIVER, ALL
THAT FROM HOUSTON BAPTIST TO
MAKE WESTERN KENTUCKY A
FORMIDABLE FOE.
IT'S INTERESTING TO WATCH.
ZAPPE HAS TO BE FIRST ON OUR
LIST FOR ACCURACY BY THE NUMBERS
AND BY WHAT HE'S ABLE TO DO.
>> YEAH.
HE WON'T STRETCH THE FIELD IN
ANY SENSE, BUT HE CAN BE THAT
PINPOINT THROWER AS A LONG-TERM
BACKUP ONCE AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S KEEP THIS MOVING.
EJ PERRY NEXT UP.
AN I'VY LEAGUE QUARTERBACK.
HE STARTED AT BOSTON COLLEGE,
WHEN HE TRANSFERRED TO BROWN, HE
PLAYED FOR HIS UNCLE.
WHEN I LOOK AT HIM, HE'S
SPECIFIC IN WHAT OFFENSE HE HAS
TO GO TO.
A TEAM LIKE BALTIMORE HAS A GOOD
LONG-TERM BACKUP IN TYLER
HUNTLEY, THAT'S WHAT I'M
THINKING.
SOMEBODY THAT CAN GET HIM
MOVING.
RUN RPO WITH HIM.
USE HIM IN THE RUN GAME AND KEEP
THAT SHORT AREA PASSING ATTACK
OPEN FOR PERRY.
HE HAS A SHOT TO GO AT THE END
OF THE DRAFT.
SEVENTH ROUND WE'RE LOOKING AT.
YOU CAN SEE THE ROLLOUT THERE.
HIS GAME HAS DEVELOPED OFF OF
THAT SHORT AREA THROWING.
>> YEAH.
IT'S SHOULDER, SHORT AREA, THE
RPO GAME.
ALL THOSE LITTLE THINGS.
AND I LOVE HIM THROWING THE BALL
FROM 11 YARDS DOWN ON A QUICK
WHEN HE'S ALSO WORKING A RUN
FAKE IN.
HIS ABILITY TO FLIP HIS HIPS IS
REMARKABLE, THAT'S SOMETHING A
LOT OF FOLKS DON'T TALK ABOUT.
HE CAN GIVE YOU A PASS FAKE TO
HIS RIGHT, FLIP THE HIPS OPEN
AND GET THE BALL BACK TO THE
LEFT BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT
LINEBACKER IS STEPPING INSIDE.
HE FITS ALONG WITH KALEB ELEBY.
THESE TWO GUYS TO ME FEEL
SIMILAR.
AM I CRAZY FOR THINKING THAT?
THEY BOTH HAVE THIS ABILITY TO
WORK REALLY QUICK IN THAT TIGHT
GAME TO CREATE PLAYS.
ULTIMATELY THE GOAL FOR YOUR
QUARTERBACK IS TO BE A POINT
GUARD, GET THE BALL TO YOUR
PLAYMAKERS TO MAKE PLAYS.
IF YOU GET IT THERE FASTER, THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE.
>> I THINK YOU NAILED IT.
ELLEBY, A SMALLER GUY, A LOT OF
THESE QUARTERBACKS ARE AROUND
6'1" SIX FEET TALL, 200 POUNDS,
210 POUNDS.
HE WILL TRY TO LAYER THE FIELD
WITH TOUCH THROWS.
HE MOVES WELL.
HE DOMINATED IN THE CONFERENCE.
THERE'S TIMES WHEN THE HEAT GETS
TURNED UP.
YOU COULD SEE THIS WHEN HE
PLAYED MICHIGAN.
HE STARTED TO AIM A LITTLE BIT
RATHER THAN THROW.
WHEN HE GETS TIME AND THE
OFFENSE OPENS UP FOR HIM, YOU'RE
SEEING HIM GO OUT THERE AND
SPLAY THE BALL AROUND.
JUMP IN, FELDER WHAT HAVE YOU
SEEN WITH ELEBY?
>> CAN WE RUN THIS CLIP BACK
AGAIN?
WE CAN CUT IT AFTER THE
PITTSBURGH PLAY.
I WANT FOLKS TO LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS HERE.
THIS IS WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
WITH FLIPPING THE HIPS.
IT'S REMARKABLE THE SPEED, THE
PLAY AFTER THIS.
I'LL WAIT TO GET TO IT.
HIS ABILITY TO FLIP HIS HIPS.
WE SEE IT OUT OF -- HERE IT IS.
LOOK AT THIS.
GET MY HIPS BACK AND RESET TO
MAKE THIS THROW TO THE INTERIOR.
2459S
THAT'S HARD TO DO.
THAT'S SOMETHING, WHEN IT COMES
TO RHYTHM PASSING, QUICKNESS AND
ACCURACY, IT'S REALLY HARD TO
DO.
THE BACK WENT THE WRONG WAY ON
THE FAKE BUT HE GOT HIS HIPS
FLIPPED AND WAS ABLE TO GET THE
BALL TO THAT SLANT.
HE CAN DO IT, ZAPPE CAN DO IT.
EJ PERRY, HIM AND EJ PERRY ARE
GOOD AT IT.
I WANTED TO GET THAT IN THERE.
ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE US TO THE
QUESTIONS OR ARE WE ENDING UP ON
THE WILDCARDS?
>> LET'S GET TO THE WILDCARD
QUARTERBACKS AND THEN DIVE INTO
THE COMMENTS.
WE GOT THOSE ROLLING IN.
BROCK PURDY, I'LL LET YOU TAKE
THIS ONE AWAY.
YOU WATCHED HIM FOR A LONG TIME.
THESE ARE THE WILDCARDS, LONG
SHOTS TO BE DRAFTED OR HANG ON
IN THE LEAGUE FOR A LONG TIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT BROCK PURDY,
WHAT'S THE CALLING CARD TRAIT
THAT CAN KEEP HIM AROUND THE NFL
FOR A BIT?
>> I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE A FIRST
ROUND DRAFT PICK AFTER HIS
FRESHMAN YEAR.
>> YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
>> I THINK THIS IS WHAT WILL
KEEP HIM IN.
HIS TRUST OF HIS PLAYERS.
THERE'S A TRUST AND
UNDERSTANDING, YOU CAN SEE THE
ATHLETICISM.
THE TRUST THAT HE HAS IN HIS
TEAMMATES, WHETHER IT'S CHARLIE
KOHLER, BREECE HALL, HIS ABILITY
TO UNDERSTAND THAT EVEN WHEN
THEY'RE NOT OPEN, THEY'RE OPEN.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO
HAVE IN THE NFL.
HIS ABILITY TO BUY TIME WITH THE
LEGS.
PURDY IS STILL A VIABLE --
SOLUTION IS NOT THE RIGHT WORD.
I WILL SAY HE'S A VIABLE OPTION
AT THE QUARTERBACK SPOT.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO WILL BE
REMARKABLY SERVICEABLE AND
ULTIMATELY CAN -- YOU MENTIONED
THE CASE KEENUM COMP FOR SAM
HOWELL.
I THINK BROCK PURDY FEELS TO ME
LIKE A PLUSSED UP TJ YATES.
I LOVE TJ WITH ALL MY HEART
TRULY AS A FRIEND.
THIS IS A LITTLE PLUSSED UP TJ.
WON A PLAYOFF GAME FOR THE
TEXANS.
LET'S GO.
>> LET'S KEEP THE WILDCARDS
MOVING.
I'M ROLLING WITH AQEEL GLASS, A
TWO-TIME CAPTAIN, HUGE PLAYER AT
THE POSITION.
ABOUT 6'5", CARRIES THAT WEIGHT
WELL.
STILL DEVELOPING.
BUT MONSTER NUMBERS THIS YEAR
FOR ALABAMA AND A&M.
I WAS SURPRISED AND HURT THAT HE
WASN'T INVITED TO THE NFL
COMBINE.
THIS IS SOMEBODY YOU LOOK AT AND
GO I WOULD STASH HIM ON THE
PRACTICE SQUAD, DEVELOP HIM AND
SEE WHAT I HAVE BECAUSE OF THE
UPSIDE OF WHAT HE HAS.
WAS HE ASKED TO BE A HERO ALL
THE TIME?
NOT NECESSARILY.
BUT IS HE ASKED TO DROP THE BALL
IN?
THAT'S THE NAME OF HIS GAME.
DROP BACK, I'LL GIVE THE GUY A
CHANCE.
SO AQEEL GLASS IS SOMEONE,
DESPITE NOT GETTING THAT COMBINE
INVITE, I WOULDN'T BE SHOCKED TO
HEAR HIS NAME CALLED OFF THE
BOARD IN ROUND SEVEN.
AS WE ROUND THIS OUT, YOU TEASED
IT EARLIER, COLE KELLEY, AQEEL
GLASS, NFL P.A. BOWL PLAYERS FOR
THE DRIFT.
A GOOD SIGN FOR THEM GETTING
DRAFTED.
YOU HINTED AT A QUARTERBACK WHO
LOADS UP LIKE A BAZOOKA.
YOU FOLLOWED COLE KELLEY FOR A
LONG TIME.
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN IN HIS GAME?
HE'S A GIANT AT THE POSITION.
>> HE'S HUGE.
IT TAKES HIM FOREVER TO THROW
THE FOOTBALL.
THAT'S THE PART THAT'S
INTERESTING.
YOU SEE IT THERE, THAT WASN'T
SLOW MOTION.
THIS IS SLOW MOTION.
THE OTHER PART WAS JUST HIM
THROWING.
IT TAKES HIM A LONG TIME.
YOU WONDER HOW LONG HE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO DEVELOP AND HOW LONG
PEOPLE -- CAN YOU SHORTEN UP
THAT DELIVERY?
WHAT CAN YOU DO WITH IT?
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION.
THAT'S THE WAY HE THROWS THE
FOOTBALL AND HOW HE'S
COMFORTABLE THROWING THE
FOOTBALL.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH COLE
KELLEY.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING.
CONNOR, TAKE US TO THE COMMENTS
SO WE CAN GET TO THE DIVISIONAL
BREAKDOWN.
>> LET'S FIRE AWAY HERE.
THE REAL GM SAYS EJ PERRY THE
PRIDE OF ANDOVER, MASSACHUSETTS.
CRUMP 150 SAYS ZAPPE IS COLT
BRENNAN.
ALONSO SAYS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A PROJECTED SEVENTH ROUND
QUARTERBACK, SHOWS HOW WEAK THIS
QUARTERBACK CLASS IS.
YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
CRUMP SAYS PURDY IS MARC BULGER.
LET'S GET INTO THE DIVISIONAL
BREAKDOWN.
THE COMMENTS HAVE BEEN BRINGING
IT TODAY.
I LIKE THE PLAYER COMP
SUGGESTIONS.
BEFORE THAT, WE HAVE TO DO
PLAYER PROPS.
DRAFT PROPS.
LET'S STICK WITH THE
QUARTERBACKS AND KICK IT OFF
HERE.
FIRST QUARTERBACK OFF THE BOARD,
WE KNOW IT'S A TWO-MAN RACE
HERE.
WHO DO YOU LIKE?
>> I'M GOING MALIK WILLIS.
I'M NOT A GAMBLER.
I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF THE
GAMBLING TERMINOLOGY.
I WILL KEEP MY MONEY IN MY
POCKET AND GO MALIK WILLIS.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I'M ROLLING WITH KENNY
PICKETT, ONLY BECAUSE OF THE
PLUS MONEY.
WILLIS IS THE FAVORITE.
HE CAN GO SIXTH OVERALL, IN A
TRADE-UP SCENARIO.
I'LL TAKE PICKETT'S PLUS MONEY,
PLUS 175 FOR PICKETT AND A BIT
OF A SURPRISE.
THIS ONE NOT AS TIGHT.
FIRST RUNNING BACK OFF THE
BOARD, BREECE HALL FOR ME.
I'M NOT GOING TO OVERTHINK THIS.
MINUS 250.
A HEAVY, HEAVY FAVORITE.
HE'S IN MY TOP 30 PLAYERS.
I DON'T HAVE A RUNNING BACK
AFTER THAT UNTIL ABOUT 49 FOR
KENNETH WALKER.
BREECE HALL IS A STUD.
A WORKHORSE.
I THINK HE COMES IN AND STARTS
AS A BACK FOR AN NFL TEAM.
ARE YOU ROLLING WITH ME ON THIS
ONE?
>> WE'RE IN LOCK STEP ON THIS
ONE.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHEN THE RUNNING BACKS COME OFF
THE BOARD IN THIS ONE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THESE OTHER
GUYS, WHETHER IT'S DAMIAN
PETERSON OR KENNETH WALKER, TIE
CHANDLER FROM UNC, ALL THESE
GUYS ARE KIND OF CLUSTERED
TOGETHER AFTER BREECE.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHERE THEY FIT.
>> A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
AFTERNOON INTERESTING ONE, NOT
AS CUT AND DRY.
WIDE RECEIVER, FIRST WIDE
RECEIVER OFF THE BOARD.
GARRETT WILSON IS THE FAVORITE.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE RUNNER
UP, DRAKE LONDON PLUS 135.
I LIKE THAT PLUS MONEY.
I SAID ATLANTA COULD TRADE UP
EARLIER, IF THEY DON'T, LONDON
COULD GO OFF THE BOARD AT 8 OR
10 TO THE NEW YORK JETS.
ABOVE THE RIM RECEIVER,
OBVIOUSLY NUMBER ONE POTENTIAL.
HEARD A BIT OF A RUMOR, EVEN IF
HE DOESN'T RUN, HE WAS PROJECTED
TO LOG ABOUT A 4.57 40, WHICH IS
A GREAT TIME AT HIS SIZE.
YOU SEE THE BASKETBALL ABILITY
ON THE FIELD.
FELDER, I KNOW YOU LIKE DRAKE
LONDON BUT I KNOW YOU LIKE
SOMEONE ELSE FOR FIRST WIDE
RECEIVER OFF THE BOARD.
>> YEAH.
I LIKE DRAKE LONDON, I LOVE
JAMESON WILLIAMS.
I'LL ROLL WITH HIM.
GARRETT WILSON IS GOOD.
OLAVE, DODSON.
I'M GOING JAMESON WILLIAMS.
HE'S A GUY THAT EVEN COMING OFF
AN INJURY -- THE CRAZY THING
HERE IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
GUYS COMING OFF OF INJURIES.
WE STILL THINK THEY WILL GO
ABOVE GARRETT WILSON WHO IS
HEALTHY AND FOLKS WILL -- HAVE
GOT TO SEE HIM PLAY.
I'M GOING JAMESON WILLIAMS ON
THIS ONE.
I WILL STICK WITH THIS ONE.
WE ALSO HAVE OFFENSIVE LINEMEN
ON THE PROP BOARD.
I WILL STICK WITH ALABAMA.
FIRST OFFENSIVE LINEMAN OFF THE
BOARD, EVAN NEAL, I'M TAKING
HIM.
>> FELDER RIDING THE JUICE HERE.
JAMESON WILLIAMS PLUS 850.
NEAL PLUS 105.
THAT WOULD BE SERIOUS RETURN ON
YOUR INVESTMENT.
I HAVE TO GO WITH AQUANO.
I THINK THEY'LL WANT A BIG, BAD
BULLY TO RESET THIS FRANCHISE
THE NEW ENGLAND WAY.
AND I THINK HE'LL FIT THAT MOLD.
YOU SEE HOW CLOSE THOSE ODDS ARE
BETWEEN HIM AND EVAN NEAL, IT
WILL BE FASCINATING TO SEE WHICH
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN AND WHICH WIDE
RECEIVER COMES OFF THE BOARD
FIRST.
I KNOW "BLEACHER REPORT" VIEWERS
LOVE THE COMMENT AND THE DRAFT
PROPS.
HERE WE HAVE IT.
BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE, WE
ALWAYS DO A DIVISIONAL
BREAKDOWN.
HE WOULD SHOWING YOU LOVE.
WE HAVE THE COMMENTS COMING UP.
OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR
RACE WILL BE FUN THIS YEAR SAYS
C. McCULLOUGH.
I AGREE.
DO YOU THINK FIVE WIDE RECEIVERS
GO IN THE FIRST ROUND?
WE HAVE TIME FOR THIS ONE.
I THINK ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULD TAKE THE OVER.
JUMP IN.
>> WE HAVE LONDON, OLAVE,
WILSON, WILLIAMS, AM I
FORGETTING SOMEBODY?
BURKS.
>> YEAH.
COULD BE DODSON AT THE BACK END.
>> CHRISTIAN WATSON.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
>> I SAY SEVEN.
>> BOOM.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DIVISIONAL BREAKDOWN.
WE HAVE THE AFC SOUTH ON TAP
THIS WEEK.
FELDER BROUGHT IT.
HE HAS PLAYERS GALORE FOR US IN
THE AFC SOUTH.
WE'RE DONE LOOKING AT THESE
FIRST-ROUNDERS EVERY SINGLE
WEEK.
WE'RE GETTING INTO THE NITTY
GRITTY.
WE ARE FOUR WEEKS OUT FROM THE
NFL DRAFT.
HERE ARE YOUR TEAM NEEDS.
LET'S START WITH THE TITANS.
THEY NEED A LINEBACKER, THEY
COULD USE ANOTHER WIDE RECEIVER.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT OFFENSIVE
LINE EARLIER IN THE SHOW.
FELDER, I KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR
EYES ON NOT ONE BUT TWO
LINEB
LINEBACKERS, WHO DO YOU LIKE?
>> NAKOBE DEAN.
DO YOU THINK HE'LL BE AROUND
WHEN THEY PICK 26th?
>> I DO.
I THINK THE FACT THAT HE DIDN'T
TEST, I HEARD A RUMOR THAT HE
WAS REALLY BANGED UP.
HE'S NOT HIDING ANYTHING, HE'S
AN ATHLETE.
HE'S A SMALLER GUY.
THE SHORTER LINEBACKERS IN THIS
LEAGUE HAVE TO WAIT TO HEAR
THEIR NAME CALLED LONGER.
I THINK HE'LL MAKE IT TO THE END
OF ROUND ONE.
>> AND THEN I HAVE TO GO -- IF
WE'RE GOING DEEPER, WE'RE GOING
PICKS 131, 169-ISH, CORDIELL
FLAT, BUT CAN HE DO ANYTHING
OTHER THAN PLAY MAN?
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
FOR THAT TEAM, THEY DON'T NEED
HIM NECESSARILY TO LIVE ON THE
OUTSIDE.
I LIKE YOUR DEFENSIVE MINDED
APPROACH FOR A TEAM THAT'S HAD A
LOT OF INJURIES AT THAT SPOT.
THE RA EVANS DID NOT WORK OUT.
AND HE IS MORE OF A VALUE PICK.
YOU'RE LOOKING OUTSIDE THE TOP
100.
THAT'S WHERE HE'S PROJECTED TO
GO.
A LOT OF UPSIDE IN THAT
SELECTION AS WELL.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE TEXANS.
QUARTERBACK, OFFENSIVE LINE,
EDGE, SAFETY, WIDE RECEIVER.
LINEBACKER, NEEDS GALORE ON THIS
ROSTER.
I BROUGHT UP ICKY EARLIER AT
NUMBER THREE.
IF THEY DON'T GO THAT ROUTE, WHO
DO YOU LIKE?
>> YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT
TWEENERS BEFORE.
DO THEY PICK DARREN AT THE TOP
OF THE ROUND?
PLAYED TACKLE AND MIGHT BE
BETTER AT GUARD THEN YOU FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO DO WITH HIM BECAUSE
HE'S THE BEST LINEMAN ON THE
BOARD?
>> I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
LANDING SPOT.
HE'S SOMEBODY THAT IS NOT GOING
TO GO IN THE FIRST 25 PICKS.
YOU GET IN CAMP AND FIND OUT.
IF HE CAN'T PROTECT THAT EDGE,
YOU CAN KICK HIM INSIDE.
YOU HAVE ONE OF THE BEST IMPACT
RUN BLOCKERS IN THE DRAFT FOR A
TEAM THAT HAS THE WORST RUN GAME
IN THE NFL LAST YEAR.
IT'S GOT TO GET BETTER FOR THE
TEXANS THERE.
WE KNOW, BESIDES BRANDIN COOKS,
THEY'VE BEEN TROTTING OUT
BORDERLINE ROSTER PLAYERS AT
WIDE RECEIVER.
YOU HAD ONE IN STORE HERE FOR A
LATER PICK.
WHO DO YOU LIKE TO ADD TO THIS
WIDE RECEIVER GROUP?
>> JALEN NAILOR.
MY WIFE WAS A SPARTAN, THEY LOVE
PA
SPARTY THERE.
I WONDER HOW FAST HE ACTUALLY
IS.
IN GAMES, THERE'S TIMES WHERE HE
LOOKS EXPLOSIVE.
OTHER TIMES HE CAN'T GET THE
SEPARATION HE WANTS.
A LOT OF THAT IS DEPENDENT UPON
THE DEFENSIVE BACK HE WANTS.
AGAINST RUTGERS, WIDE OPEN.
I GUESS WHERE DO YOU THINK HE
FITS?
HERE, HE'S NOT OPEN ON THAT PLAY
AGAINST IOWA BUT HE FINDS WAYS
BASED ON THE THROW AND BODY
MOVEMENT TO CREATE SPACE.
HE'S A CRAFTY WIDE RECEIVER.
HE CAN FIND A WAY TO GET OPEN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THAT
TRANSLATES TO THE NFL.
HOW HIGH CAN HE BE PICKED?
DO YOU THINK HE'S AN ASSET TO
THE TEXANS?
>> I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
FIFTH ROUND FOR HIM.
WE'VE SEEN FIFTH ROUND WIDE
RECEIVERS HANG ON IN THE NFL FOR
A LONG TIME.
HE RAN A 4.5 40 AT THE COMBINE.
AVERAGE SPEED FOR HIS SIDE.
38-INCH VERTICAL IS A GOOD SIGN.
THAT SHOWED UP TO ME ON FILM.
THE ABILITY TO BE A MORE
EXPLOSIVE THREAT DOWN THE FIELD
FOR THAT OFFENSE IS WHAT TOOK
OUT.
N
NAILOR WAS ONE OF MY SURPRISES
OF THE SEASON.
I LOOKED AT HIM AND WENT FOR
SOMEBODY WHO COULD GO BACK TO
SCHOOL, HE COULD BE DRAFTED.
HE'S NOT WAITING UNTIL THE SIXTH
OR SEVENTH ROUND.
HE'S ONE OF THE MORE BARGAIN
RELATED WIDE RECEIVERS IN THE
DRAFT THAT'S NOT GETTING ENOUGH
LOVE.
I THINK HE PLAYS A TOUGH GUY
GAME WHICH MATTERS SOMEWHAT AT
THE NEXT LEVEL.
HE WILL MIX IT UP AS A BLOCKER.
IF YOU NEED TO TRUST YOUR WIDE
RECEIVERS TO BLOCK ON THE
OUTSIDE, HE WILL BRING THAT AS
WELL.
NAILOR, GLAD TO GET HIM INVOLVED
IN THE SHOW.
JACKSONVILLE, WE SAW THIS TEAM
SPEND AN UNBELIEVABLE AMOUNT OF
MONEY IN FREE AGENCY.
THEY ALSO HAVE BIG-TIME PICKS.
FIRST OVERALL, 33rd OVERALL.
THE TOP OF THE SECOND ROUND
WHERE YOU CAN GET ONE OF THOSE
FIRST-ROUNDERS THAT FELL.
THEY NEED "D" LINE, WIDE
RECEIVERS.
MAYBE LINEBACKER OR SAFETY.
THIS TEAM HAS A LOT OF LONG-TERM
NEEDS.
I ALREADY KNOW THE DIRECTION
YOU'RE GOING FOR THEM AT
DEFENSIVE BACK.
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS IN THE DRAFT, SO BREAK
IT DOWN.
>> DAXTON HILL IS REMARKABLE TO
WATCH.
IF THEY CAN GET HIM AT 33, RUN
DON'T WALK AND GET THAT CARD IN.
HE CAN BLITZ.
YOU SEE HIM HERE PLAYING LEVELS
AS AN INSIDE CORNER.
NO PROBLEM.
SINKING INTO COVERAGE TO MAKE AN
INTERCEPTION.
HE CAN PLAY ZONE OR MAN.
YOU CAN SEE HIM HERE COMING
ACROSS THE FORMATION AND STILL
OUTRUNNING A GUY TO STOP THE
FIRST DOWN.
HE DOES EVERYTHING.
I SAT DOWN TODAY AND DREW UP
MULTIPLE PLAYS.
YOU LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK AT THAT.
A LITTLE BIT OF SLICE COVERAGE.
I LOVE THAT.
THAT'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
FOOTBALL.
HIS VERSATILITY IS AMAZING.
HIS ABILITY IS AMAZING.
HE'S WHAT PEOPLE THOUGHT JABRILL
PEPPERS WAS GOING TO BE AND WAS.
HE IS A TRUE SAFETY THAT CAN
PLAY AT FREE SAFETY.
HE IS LINED UP AT FREE SAFETY,
INSIDE CORNER, OUTSIDE CORNER,
HE'S LINED UP AT STRONG SAFETY.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING.
AT 33, IF YOU'RE THE JAGS AT 33
AND HE'S ON THE BOARD, ARE YOU
NOT RUNNING THAT CARD IN?
>> IT'S THE EASIEST PICK YOU CAN
MAKE.
33 FOR JACKSONVILLE, 35 FOR THE
NEW YORK JETS.
HE'S GOING IN THE TOP 40.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE TEAMS
THAT ARE PICKING IN THAT RANGE
THAT NEED SAFETIES ON THE BACK
END.
FELDER, WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ON
YOUR PODCAST, HE IS JUST SUCH A
GOOD DYNAMIC ATHLETE.
YOU TRUST HIM ANYWHERE.
HE CAN BE A MATCH-UP PLAYER
AGAINST TIGHT ENDS.
HE CAN PLAY TWO HIGH, SINGLE
HIGH.
HE'S THAT ATHLETIC.
HE IS INTENSE.
HE STOOD OUT ON THE MICHIGAN
DEFENSE WHEN AIDAN HUTCHISON AND
DAVID OJABO WERE GETTING THAT
LOVE, YOU DON'T ALWAYS SEE IT ON
THE TV, BUT ON THE COACH'S TAPE
YOU COULD SEE IT.
DAXTON HILL IS GOING TOP 40.
SPECIAL ATHLETE, SPECIAL PLAYER.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE IN THE BARGAIN
AISLE MAYBE ON DAY THREE OF THE
DRAFT?
>> MAYBE JUST THE CHICAGO FEEL
BECAUSE I'M HERE.
I'M GOING CHRIS BERGEN.
LINEBACKER FROM NORTHWESTERN.
ONE OF THE LEADERS IN TACKLES IN
THE COUNTRY.
I THINK HE LED THE COUNTRY IN
TACKLES PER GAME.
SECOND OR THIRD IN THE COUNTRY
IN TOTAL TACKLES.
THIS IS A GUY, A BIT UNDERSIZED.
A BIT UNDER HEIGHT.
HE RAN WELL IN HIS PRO DAY,
TESTED WELL FROM A VERTICAL
STANDPOINT.
FLEXED OUT OVER THE SLOT.
YEAH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
GUY?
I'VE WATCHED HIM.
HE CAN PLAY.
THIS GUY WILL BE THE TRAD
TRADITIONAL, LIKE, I'M A DOG.
I'LL DO WHAT I CAN DO.
>> I LOVE HIS RANGE.
I LOVE HIS SUBPACKAGE ABILITY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BERGEN, YOU
DRAFT HIM.
YOU SAID THAT ABOUT THE PRO DAY,
THAT 6'5" THREE CONE IS
SOMETHING.
HE MAY NOT BE TAKING ON
BLOCKERS, BUT I CAN WEAVE, BEAT
YOU TO THE SIDELINE, YOU CAN PUT
HIM AS A NICKEL BACKER TO RUN
AND TAKE AWAY SLOTS IN COVERAGE.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT HIM WITH THAT
ATHLETIC PROFILE, HE CAN BE A
SPECIAL TEAMS ACE AT THE PRO
LEVEL, WHETHER IT'S COVERING
KICKS AND PUNTS, THE ABILITY TO
RUN DOWNFIELD.
THE MENTALITY AS WELL.
BERGEN, I'M GLAD.
THAT IS MORE OF A -- BEFORE THE
PRO DAY, HE WAS CHALLENGING TO
BE DRAFTED BECAUSE A LOT OF
THOSE GUYS ARE PRIORITY UDFA's
TO BE SPECIALS.
YES, HE'S UNDERSIZED, BUT IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT ATHLETIC PROFILE, SOMEBODY
WILL USE A PICK ON HIM.
LAST TEAM OF THE DIVISION.
THE COLTS.
THEY GOT MATT RYAN.
THEY'RE TURNING OVER A NEW ERA.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET OVER THE
HUMP HERE.
CORNER, WIDE RECEIVER FOR SURE.
DEFENSIVE LINE.
TIGHT END.
WHERE ARE YOU STARTING THINGS
OFF HERE?
>> LISTEN, YOU'RE THE EXPERT
PROJECTIONIST.
WHERE DO YOU TAKE JUSTYN ROSS?
>> ONE OF THE TOUGHEST ONES IN
THE ENTIRE DRAFT.
IF YOU ASKED ME THIS QUESTION A
COUPLE YEARS AGO, HE WAS GOING
IN THE TOP 40 PICKS.
ASKING ME NOW, WITHOUT KNOWING
MEDICALS, HONESTLY, HE'LL BE
THERE IN THE FOURTH ROUND.
I DO.
YOU JUST HOPE THAT YOU CAN HELP
HIM GET HIS BODY AND HIS MIND
RIGHT AND GET BACK TO THE KIND
OF ABOVE THE RIM PLAYER THAT HE
SHOWED TO BE SO EARLY ON IN HIS
CAREER.
>> WELL, THAT'S THE THING FOR
ME.
WATCHING HIM THIS SEASON,
WHETHER IT WAS A LEVEL OF
CONTACT SHYNESS OR NOT WANTING
TO MAKE THE CONTESTED CATCHES OR
PLAYING TO THE EDGE MORE THAN TO
THE MIDDLE.
YES, WE GET A PICTURE HERE ON A
CLEAR DIG WHEN HE'S OPEN IN THE
MIDDLE.
SO MUCH OF WHAT HE DID WAS SO
WIDE.
A LOT OF BACK SHOULDER, NOT A
LOT OF CONTESTED OR BATTLING.
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD
HERE BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT
WHERE HE DIDN'T DO A LOT OF
THESE THINGS.
THAT'S A PART OF WHY CLEMSON'S
OFFENSE SUFFERED.
THE MAIN SUFFERING GOES BACK TO
THE OFFENSIVE LINE, THERE'S
NOTHING JUSTYN ROSS CAN DO ABOUT
THAT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME NUKE OR
MIKE WILLIAMS OR T. HIGGINS, HE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT SAME MAKEUP
FROM WHAT WE'RE USED TO SEEING
OUT OF THESE CLEMSON GUYS, EVEN
SAMMY WATKINS.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING ONE FOR
ME.
ANOTHER GUY I'LL THROW IN HERE,
MAYBE IT'S A UDFA, MAYBE IT'S
INTO THE DRAFT, SIXTH, SEVENTH
ROUND, I'LL THROW IN GRANT C
CALCATERRA.
RETIRED FROM COLLEGE FOOTBALL,
FOUND A NEW HOME AT SMU.
LOVED HIM COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
SUPER ATHLETIC.
HE PLAYS FLEXED OUT.
HE'S AN "F" TIGHT END IN TERMS
OF HIS ABILITY TO PLAY AS THAT
FLECKED O
FLEXED OUT OPTION.
HE'S GROWING AS A BLOCKER.
AT THE END OF THE DRAFT, TO GIVE
MATT RYAN SOMETHING.
I'M NOT SAYING HE'S KYLE PITTS,
BUT HE'S GOT SOME ABILITY TO AT
LEAST STRETCH THE FIELD.
>> I THINK HE GETS DRAFTED.
I THINK HE'S LOOKING IN THE
FIFTH ROUND RANGE WHICH IS
GREAT, BIG SLOT, HOW DO YOU GET
THE BALL IN HIS HANDS.
HE SHOWED THIS YEAR YOU CAN
TRUST HIM TO BLOCK DEFENSIVE
BACKS AND SAFETIES ON THE
OUTSIDE, ESPECIALLY IN THE
ZONE-HEAVY SCHEMES.
GETTING THAT SENIOR BOWL INVITE
WAS A GREAT SIGN FOR HIM WHO WAS
ABLE TO REMAKE HIS CAREER AFTER
THAT MEDICAL RETIREMENT.
YOU SEE THE PROJECTED FITS HERE.
FELDER DID SOME BARGAIN
SHOPPING, DID SOME PREMIUM
SHOPPING.
YOU CAN SEE KIN ENARD TO THE
TEXANS.
LET'S GET INTO THE COMMENTS
BEFORE WE SIGN OFF.
FEL
BRING JAMES COOK TO DUVAL.
I KNOW YOU LOVE THAT FIT FOR
TREVOR LAWRENCE.
>> YEAH.
A GADGET PLAYER THAT CAN DO
ANYTHING.
HE'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE PLAYERS
IN THIS GROUP.
HE CAN FLEX OUT.
HE CAN OBVIOUSLY MOTION.
THE COOL THING ABOUT HIM, HE CAN
LINE UP IN THE BACKFIELD AND
MOTION OUT.
THERE'S SOMETHING DIFFERENT
ABOUT LINING UP IN THE
BACKFIELD, FORCING A TEAM TO
MOVE WITH YOU, WHICH SHOWS THEIR
HAND IN COVERAGE, OPENS UP THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIELD, AND NOW YOU
CAN SNEAK THINGS IN BEHIND.
GIVE ME JAMES COOK.
>> I'LL RIP OFF A COUPLE HERE
AND THEN SIGN OFF.
IF YOU WASTE A PICK ON BAILEY
ZAPPE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL
YOU.
SOUNDS LIKE OUR COMMENT SECTION
IS NOT A FAN OF THE DAY THREE
QUARTERBACKS.
SHOWEDER 4 W
CHOWDER 4 WANTS THE COLTS TO
TAKE A CORNER INSTEAD OF A
RECEIVER.
COLTS WILL WIN THE DIVISION.
NOT A BAD PICK HERE.
THE LAST ONE FROM ERIC, THE JAGS
WILL TAKE GEORGE PICKENS AT 33.
FELDER S THAT TOO EARLY FOR
GEORGE PICKENS?
>> IF -- IF DAX HILL IS ON THE
BOARD AT 33 AND YOU DON'T TAKE
HIM, YOU MADE A MISTAKE.
IF HE'S OFF THE BOARD, NOW
THINGS GET MORE COMPLICATED.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
PICKENS AT 33.
I LIKE HIM AS A PLAYER.
LITERALLY I WAS SHOOTING A VIDEO
ABOUT HIM, I INCLUDED THE
GEORGIA TECH FIGHT AND SOME
BLOCKING CLIPS.
HE'S ONE OF THE FEW GUYS THAT I
WOULD CALL A TONE-SETTER AT WIDE
RECEIVER.
I LIKE IT.
IT'S JUST MATTER OF HIS HEALTH
AND HOW YOU USE HIM.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE ONCE AGAIN FOUR WEEKS
AWAY FROM THE NFL DRAFT AS WE
SIT HERE ON ANOTHER EPISODE OF
"DRAFT CRASH COURSE."
QUARTERBACKS IN THE BOOKS.
I THINK YOU AND I ARE HAPPY
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S AN INTERESTING QUARTERBACK
YEAR.
BUT NOT A STAR-STUDDED
QUARTERBACK YEAR.
WE HAD SOME FUN WITH THE TRADES.
AS ALWAYS, WE WILL BE BACK NEXT
WEEK, 1:00 P.M. EASTERN TIME
HERE IN THE "BLEACHER REPORT"
APP.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS, HE'S MICHAEL
FELDER, SAME TIME, SAME PLACE
NEXT WEEK.